the weak law of large numbers tells us
that the sample mean that is the average
of independent identically distributed
random variables X I converges in a
certain sense to a number namely the
expected value of the random variables X
I but it does not tell us much about the
details of the distribution of the
sample mean the central limit theorem
provides us exactly with this kind of
detail it tells us that the sum of many
independent identically distributed
random variables has approximately a
normal distribution the mean and
variance of this normal is easy to find
if we know the mean and variance of the
original random variables this enables
us to carry out approximate calculations
rather quickly by using the normal
tables we will start with a precise
statement of the central limit theorem
and we will emphasize that it is a
universal result it holds no matter what
the distribution of the original random
variables and for this reason it is very
useful we will work through several
examples of the typical ways that the
central limit theorem is used we will
develop a refinement that can be used
when we are dealing with discrete
distributions which provides us with
even more accurate approximations and
finally we will revisit the polling
problem and inquire again about the
number of samples that are needed to
obtain a certain accuracy with a certain
confidence we will see that the central
limit theorem is much more informative
much less conservative compared to the
conclusions that we had gotten before
based on the chebyshev inequality